hi all uh huge congratulations uh by
nice in it twice
uh the second time i did like space it
out a little bit so
and there's a little bit of a difference
there um i want to start asking
sandra i talked to her about uh
voicing kintek and and standing with all
of these legends but how was it for you
uh joining into the cast and
and your experience with it you mean
drawing or voicing not voicing oh my
gosh it was so surreal you know like it
was a little intimidating because we did
both english and spanish
and uh
it's kind of like a mind meld because
you have to like really figure out what
you're gonna say and whether the accent
is gonna come through or not and uh
finally seeing it on the screen it's
it's like
it's really trippy and i had to trick
you and he had to trick me too because
originally it was supposed to be
scratch and and he was like don't worry
don't worry we'll get back to it but
then i began to see all of like like the
actual episodes being edited towards the
end and i was still in it and i was like
when are you gonna get queen tekka and
he was like oh
and then by the end of it i was there i
was like you dropped your crown queen
um well basically on that conversation
how was working together on the on on
the show
um
especially after having worked together
on projects before how was that dynamic
changed over the years i think it was
smooth honestly like jorge would love to
say that there was a lot of drama but it
was so bad he's such a drama queen i
swear no but we've been working together
for so long i think that we have a
really nice repertoire going you know
and we learn like what we're both good
at and what we're both our strengths and
weaknesses and weaknesses and you know
we've been working together for 20 years
and
we've never not worked together so it's
we say we dance really well together now
all we have to do is chop off certain
toes yeah
um
i am fascinated by the the character
designs in in maya um can you talk a bit
about of coming up with those designs
and all the different uh
the shapes the noses the mouths oh well
when it comes to our design style i
think that jorge is a little more
organic i'm a little
i'm a little more
elegant i would say would you say it was
like yeah yeah so that's again like when
we work together that's how we help each
other we're super greek reciprocally
yeah is that a way to get it yeah
because you give me like like tips on
how to make my stuff a little more
organic and flowy and when you jorge
tends to go a little too crazy with his
designs i mean there's a character
called
nickland and how many skulls are there
666
yeah sometimes he needs to pull back a
little yeah so well and you know the
other thing that we learned is you want
to make something beautiful
you put something ugly next to it just
like beauty and the beast like we use
the contrast and so we we tend to design
together and we tend to
i mean we love toys of course yeah so we
tend to design things to look like
figures that we want we want to get made
so we can have them oh yeah all this
movie stuff is just an excuse to buy
those toys more toys
right um
gabriel actually talked to me like he
said that the one thing he wanted to add
to his character was a merchandise deal
um for peaches so like yeah there you go
oh my god yeah i wish there were toys i
wish i was a pizza i'm dying to make
toys
um jorge when when you were crafting the
world and and the characters that you
wanted to bring in how closely if at all
do you want to
stick to what was already from like
mythology and from mesoamerican
mythology versus creating your own
version
i i wanted to be very respectful so i
did a ton of research but then at the
same time i wanted to do a cover right i
wanted to do my version my fantasy
version of it so just like book of life
was my fantasy version of day of the
dead this was my fantasy version of
mesoamerica and caribbean cultures and
of course the incan but at the same time
i wanted for people who know this stuff
to go oh look he's representing this
legend he's referencing this design that
god is based on this god like there's a
bazillion layers to everything we made
and i really think for me at least the
way i research things gives me ideas and
then i try to make a lasagna of layers
of information and you know there's
references to street fighter and ninja
squirrel and kira and all these movies
that i love
and mets of america and i think that's
what we do in latin america yeah we take
things from all over the world and we
reconceive them as our own
there are a lot of you mentioned that
the references and not only do you
reference all of these pop culture icons
but you reference your own stuff uh i
saw a bit of a tigran and book of life
uh how was that and are you creating
your own little multiverse here that's
kind of crazy yeah sandra calls it the
jorge verse
it's like sometimes i'll be talking to
you about something and i was like
didn't i see that in that other project
are you gonna use that now
and it's like yeah well why not yeah i
mean they all exist it all comes from my
head so of course they're in the same
universe and i i would love for
characters right yeah i would love for
characters from all these worlds to meet
one day because they certainly meet in
my head so
crazy that'll be a crazy story
yeah
um
when you're looking uh when you when you
look at the final product for the first
time what was the thing that you that
most surprised you that you weren't
exactly sure it was gonna work but then
you saw it you're like yeah it works man
for me it was ow my god it works
as a whole because it's so detailed and
so fast-paced
you know that everything it's like a
symphony that came together in the end
there was the music the visuals the
lighting the backgrounds everything and
in the end it was just all tied up in
this perfect package yeah i i will admit
early on people were saying hey this is
really weird and complex and these
characters are really busy and the
stories are there's like a lot of drama
but a lot of comedy like is this all
gonna work and i would have to stand
there and be like
a hundred percent is gonna work and then
i would go to my office close the door
and be like i hope it works
[Laughter]
um lastly uh i i want to ask jorge um
you mentioned the the balance and the
humor and the drama but there's also
some really dark stuff here um property
that's primarily
an all-encompassing audience um how do
you balance that how much do you wanna
like sort of push that boundary in a way
well i mean i love animation and i love
the medium and so if you go back to
bambi and you go back to you know uh
fighting nemo it's a lot of tragedy that
happens in those movies
uh lion king and so it's part of our
tradition in fairy tales to have
darkness to
basically contrast the light and in all
stories you can't have
joy without sadness exactly and so we
gotta we gotta be able to paint with all
those colors
awesome thank you so much pleasure
talking to you and huge congratulations
rafael thank you thank you thank you
thank you
you're the only person i know who's seen
it twice though why
you should get a prize
and i'm probably gonna say it again when
it comes out and start showing it to
people oh my gosh
you gotta watch it in spanish in spanish
it's like
that's my next time that's my next time
for sure i thank you bye bye